[Applause]
what i'm curious about is like what
happens to comedy now with biden as
president
and i think comedy
edgy comedy becomes a lot easier for
people to do and i think you start to
see
uh programs like snl but also like
stand-ups and a lot of people becoming
edgy and pushing back
because you always as a comic want to
push back against the institution
in power so pushing back against the
institution in power when biden is in
power
is going to be at least calling out the
hypocrisy of that institution
people felt uncomfortable calling out
the left when trump is in power because
they
thought that was an immediate indictment
of being a trumper right so i think a
lot of people
who i think a lot of people who all of a
sudden become like maybe edgy again
we'll do it because it's a comfortable
environment to be edgy
it's okay to be edgy because by being
edgy people aren't going to associate
you with the right
yeah you said i'm saying like for how
long did people call me [ __ ]
right when all right all this other [ __ ]
just because i was making jokes pushing
back against the left
yeah you know like forever so help me
out here because to that point
a lot of that started when barack was
president yeah i i feel
just the exact opposite of what you just
said go on like if
their times are more calm you can't be
as edgy because now you're standing out
in chaos the edginess is like oh wait
but
we got bigger things to worry about i
think it always depends on like the
industry you're in right
so like entertainment is usually pretty
left-leaning yeah
right and i think in a left-leaning
industry
you can call out certain things that
exist within
the culture if you will or within
politics or within the world
from the safety of a left-wing
administration
in other words yo this is really [ __ ]
up what y'all are doing but
i'm glad that y'all are in charge right
when you have a situation like with
trump
right and you see that like gaining like
steam and there's some power in there
and pushing back against the left and
the institutions that are kind of in
control
is an indictment on supporting that
thing on the right to some people
they're afraid of that they're afraid of
being connected to that in any single
way i see your logic i just didn't i
don't know that it played out like that
i think the anti-pc people got louder
when trump was in office
because they felt more like oh this is
this is cool now we got the anti-pc guy
in office
and i think it became i think you helped
a lot for sure i think this podcast
helped a lot
but i think it became more okay to fight
back against pc culture
when the leader of the country who's
been elected popular vote whatever who
gives a [ __ ] that guy got elected by
a lot of people right so clearly there's
something to this we can get
get back to it do you think it's fair to
say that like
and the entertainment industry never
really embraced that
yes and if you wanted to work within the
entertainment industry
you probably wouldn't take hold with
those to those beliefs i agree i just
think
it also started with obama in office the
entertainment industry was still going
after those
picking those guys so i'm not saying uh
you're wrong
i'm asking you to help me out here
because in my memory
what we were complaining about even when
obama was in office was yo
everything is this [ __ ] safe black
guy on tv and then the indian is also
gay or afraid to go outside or some
other like characteristic quirk that
he can't just be indian and they weren't
telling our stories or the comics that
they chose for these showcases weren't
edgy i think it's again entertainment is
always going to lean left
yeah when there's someone in charge
who's also left there's a little bit
more license
to make fun of it when someone is in
charge
that is right especially as polarizing
as trump
and you make fun of the left the
assumption is
yeah that you're on the right and the
right was so
[ __ ] radicalized and so radioactive
that any association with that made you
radioactive
you know and i think people were
terrified of that especially like comics
and entertainers
you know chris pratt poor chris bratt
guy just wants to [ __ ] believe in
jesus
yeah now he's a nazi who hates gays yeah
you know what i'm saying like
it was so terrifying for people that
were in the entertainment industry now
there's two different things we're
looking at the youtube world and
classical entertainment okay
i have to break those up i should have
clarified that okay
youtube explodes because the average
person is like yo i still want jokes
yeah i don't want pandering to the
entertainment industry standards
yep i still want to just laugh at [ __ ]
and sometimes the funny joke is pushing
against the left sometimes pushing
against the right yeah but let's just
make the funniest joke
yeah and i was i was thinking like
socially acceptable
um for us on the ground not really
speaking to
classical entertainment so that's right
i should have clarified that i should
have
and to your point where did you blow up
youtube of course
yeah absolutely so there's this and i
think you saw like a lot of even like
news organization organization but like
you know seeing crystal and sauger blow
up on youtube as well
and them just being you know people who
are calling out the left and the right
yeah but kind of having a little bit
more
of a fair shake if you will and i think
that people who are trying to get deals
signed by hollywood were terrified
yeah to do anything that might have
connected them with this thing was so
real radioactive
because that thing doesn't exist anymore
i think you're gonna see a lot more like
comics and like
creatives going i can make those jokes
because i'm not gonna be associated with
magga
mm-hmm you see what i'm saying yeah
trash and biden in the run-up to the
election was
really dangerous now trash of biden's
like that he's one yeah he's just like
oh
it's fine you're not a trumper because
you trashed him yeah i could see it
that's just my feeling i i also
am a little bit bummed about it because
i like
the high wire act i like
i like the stakes being that high i like
touching a topic that i know that
[ __ ] are terrified of touching
because
they could be accused of being connected
to that radioactive thing
yep and like for me that makes it
exciting yeah and
you look maybe this is just selfish but
if comedy gets to a point where it's
just like oh yeah anybody can just say
the crazy [ __ ] because
we feel comfortable with the institution
that's in power it's just like
well what's the fun i personally i just
don't think that will happen
yeah i think people you're right but you
know you understand
the sentiment might be a little bit more
comfy yeah maybe even snl
starting to feel a little bit they're
like yo we can get a little bit more
edgy because we know that this guy's in
yeah yeah if they get fined like fcc
fines and [ __ ] like that
maybe i also wonder if like a post-trump
presidency
affects like the culture a little bit
like when all of like the pc movement
started occurring probably what like
like lately i think earlier i think in
new york i started seeing the
2008 2008 really the second i moved here
i was like whoa
oh yeah what is this yeah i mean i i
didn't notice it until college obviously
so like
if that's when like it's really booming
we're like pronouns and like we have to
be aware of all these different like
microaggressions and stuff
if that's occurring people have no idea
what to even do with that trump gets in
office and is like pushing back against
that
now are we in like a post-correction
phase where people are a little more
like
uh stable as to where like they fit in
that
in that conversation you know what i
mean yeah uh
huh this is interesting we always say in
this podcast like every correction is an
over-correction right
this correction wasn't an
[Applause]
over-correction
you